we're asked to simplify log base 2 of 16
over x and like the last video this is
actually looks pretty simple already but
i'm assuming they want us to use some
logarithm properties to maybe write this
in a different way or actually maybe
expand this out a little bit so maybe we
should put the simplify in quotes maybe
they really want write this in a
different way and the logarithm property
that jumps out for me that we might want
to use is the idea that log
base b
of let me call it a
over c is equal to log base b of a
minus
log base b of c
and i'll apply it right here and then if
i have a little extra time in this video
i'll actually re-prove this why this
actually makes a lot of sense and why it
comes straight from our understanding of
exponent properties so if we just
straight apply this b in this case is 2
a in this case is 16 and c in this case
is x so you get log
base 2 of 16 divided by x is equal to
log base 2 of 16 minus log base 2 of x
and
this is asking this is the exponent that
i have to raise 2 2 to get to 16. well
would i have to raise 2 2 to get to 16.
well 2 to the 4th power is equal to 16.
so this first part evaluates to 4. now
if i raise 2 to the 4th power i get 16.
so this is another way of writing the
number four you can think of it that way
and then this is minus log
base 2 of x and we're done log
base 2 of 16 over x is equal to 4 minus
log base 2 of x so once again i don't
know if this is simpler than this right
over here but it definitely is another
way of writing it now that out of the
way i think it's fun to maybe try to
prove this to ourselves this generalized
property
is indeed the case so let's just assume
let's just assume that log
base b of a over c let's just assume
that that is equal to x so another way
of writing this is that b
to the x power is equal to a
over c now let's make a couple of other
assumptions let's assume that log
base b of a is equal to y then another
way of writing this would be
b to the y power is equal to
a
well we have a in this expression right
over here so we could rewrite it as b to
the y power
b to the y power b to the y power is
equal to a we're just assuming if we
raise b to the y power we get a or the
exponent the power that i have to raise
b 2 to get a is y now let's do the same
thing with c let's say that log
base b of c
is equal to z
another way of writing this
as an exponential equation is that b
to the z power is equal to c
well if c is equal to the b to the z
power i can rewrite this c as
b to the z to the power so given these
assumptions that x is log base b of a
over c y is this z is this we can write
this expression we can rewrite this
expression as b to the x power is equal
to
is equal to
b to the y
b to the y over b to the z
over
b to the z and we know from our exponent
properties that this thing right over
here
is the same thing as b to the y
minus z power now this is interesting we
we've just written that b to the x power
using exponent properties is the same
thing as b to the y minus z
so that tells us that x must be equal to
y minus z
y minus z or another way of thinking
about it this is x
this is x this is let me do that same
color
this is x log base b of a over c
this is x right over here which i want
to do to that pinkish color
this right over here by definition was x
this over here by definition we did it
right over here is y
we do that same green
this over here we defined as y and this
over here we defined a z
we defined as
we defined
as z and we just established that x is
equal to y minus z x is equal to y minus
z so the property comes straight out of
exponent properties